Hello. So, I would like to thank the organizer and Vinay to invite me to talk about the current
evidence of BCL2 inhibitor in the treatment of myelodysplastic syndrome. So, as you know,
the BCL2 is overexpressed and drive hypothesis resistance in the myelodysplastic clone. And
we know today that there is a synergistic effect with hypomethylating agent because hypomethylating
agent prime cell and increase the effect of BCL2 inhibitor and trigger hypoptosis.
So, today, we know that we have several BCL2 inhibitors in myelodysplastic syndrome. So,
first, there is the venetoclax, and we will discuss just after.
The results with azacitidine plus venetoclax. There is another one, the lisaptoclax. So,
there is a phase three clinical trial ongoing. And there is also the sorontoclax,
another BCL2 inhibitor. So, the lisaptoclax is a next generation designed to mitigate the specific
toxicity and hematological toxicity. And the sorontoclax is a more selective BCL2 inhibitor.
So, what we know about azacitidine plus venetoclax. So, as you know, there is a phase one BCD with
chromizing results in high-risk MDS. The overall response rate in first line for this patient
was 80%. The CR rate was 30%. And the median overall survival was 26 months.
Based on this phase one study, we know that the overall response rate in the first line for this patient was 80%. The CR rate was 30%. And the median overall survival was 26 months.
Based on this phase one study, the schedule of the treatment was the classical schedule for azacitidine
and venetoclax for 400 milligram per day during 14 days. So, unfortunately, as you know, the Verona
phase three trial was negative. So, the primary endpoint was not met. So, there is no benefit in
overall survival for azacitidine. So, there is no benefit in overall survival for azacitidine.
plus venetoclax versus azacitidine plus placebo. So today we have a few results for the azacitidine
plus lesavetoclax. So the efficacy from the phase 1b phase 2 study in patients with treatment naive
and high risk myelodysplastic syndrome was for the overall response rate 77% with composite
complete remission about 70% and we know today that there is no tumor lysis syndrome using
daily dose escalation prior cycle 1 using lesavetoclax and after the schedule is the same
as a schedule of azacitidine the classical schedule and lesavetoclax during 14 days.
And sorry and there is also
no 60 day mortality reported from this phase 1 phase 2 study.
So for the sorontoclax so it's a more selective BCL2 inhibitor but today
there is no published clinical data in MDS setting. So what we know using BCL2 inhibitors so there is
an increase of toxicity there is an increase of hematological toxicity so what we know we know that
we increase the hematological adverse event so the neutropenia around 50 to 60 percent the
thrombocytopenia around also 50 to 60 percent and 30 percent of febrile neutropenia. So today we know
to manage the combination of BCL2 inhibitors so we know to manage the combination of BCL2 inhibitors.
BCL2 inhibitor combining with a hypometallic agent with a proactive growth factor support
strict antimicrobial prophylaxis and aggressive dose modification and cycle delay.
So I know we can do that we can do a table comparing
some clinical trial but I did it. So in this table so you have the you have the you have a
so the result with the hazard alone so this is from a phase three we know we can compare because
the criteria was not the same using in the other 001 study and verona study for example but we know
that the overall response rate was around 70 percent the CR rate was
less than 20 percent and the median of our survival was 21 months for the other site they didn't plus venous inhibitors.
they didn't plus venetoclax based on the verona clinical trial so the overall response rate was
around 76 percent the composite complete remission was 46 percent and the median of our survival was
not improved 22 months with a toxicity manageable for the least after clax is from the phase 1b and
phase 2 studi so the overall response rate was 77 percent the composite complete remission was 70
percent the median of our survival was not rich based on the patient treated in the phase 1 phase
2 studi and for the moment there is no toxicity reported with no tls based on the phase 1 and phase 2 studi and you know there is no toxicity reported
no tls based on the phase 1 and phase 2 studi and you know
today there is the phase 3 glora 4 ongoing evaluating azacitidine lesaftoclax versus
azacitidine plus placebo and of course we are rating also the results from the
phase 1 and phase 2 studi combining azacitidine plus sorontoclax so thank you for your attention